It's a privilege to be here.
Thank you all for taking your time today
out of your busy day to hear me talk
about warrior women in
leadership. Um, excuse me,
I'm getting over a little bit of a cold.
So if I cough,
I hope you understand I'm armed
and dangerous with water up here.
So this is a topic that's
near and dear to my heart.
I've been doing women's leadership
work for really my whole life,
but in my corporate environments are
guide project for women's leadership arm
really goes into corporations like Google
and plenty of other places and helps
women leaders to achieve.
One of the things that's really key to
where we find ourselves right now though
at this moment in history
is that as you all know,
we're in the midst of a massive cultural
shift where like a tectonic shift in
women's leadership.
And that means certain things right now
for what women leaders are doing and the
way in which we're operating that is very
different from the messages that we've
had before and the ways in which
leadership has functioned before as well.
Because we're having more influence than
we've ever had before on the leadership
of companies, institutions, governments,
not withstanding, uh, you know,
where we find ourselves at the moment.
Um,
and also that we are in a position
where our skills as women leaders are
influencing how corporations
function generally.
So we're going to talk through today,
um,
when warrior women leadership
as it stands right now,
and give you guys some really practical
tools to walk away from in terms of what
this means and what it means
for leadership and what
it means for professional
development and also what it means
for our culture in our world. So, um,
one of the things that I want to just
start with is what is a warrior woman in
leadership?
What does that look like right now?
So when I talk about warrior women,
what I'm talking about is how we have
armed ourselves for change in this er,
this corporate and cultural
environment that we're in right now,
worried or women in leadership to me
is about an activist model of women's
leadership.
And we're going to talk through what
that looks like in the context of your
every day. But we've seen more and more
women really rising to create change,
especially in the last 12 months.
Um, I think for obvious reasons.
And we're also obviously, as I mentioned,
seeing major cultural shifts right now.
So one of the things that is important
when we talk about warrior women in
leadership is the historic backward
looking view point of where we find
ourselves.
So traditional masculine
models of leadership generally
only measure two metrics
that matter, the time that we
invest and how much money we make,
whether that's the money we
make for ourselves or the
money that is made that we
make for others.
Um,
and that those models are really
difficult for women to rise within for a
variety of reasons because many of us
choose to have children because many of us
historically also do so much more work
at home than we do out in the world. Um,
and the metrics that we measure our
success by also our difference. Um,
because generally speaking, we're more
concerned with the quality of our lives.
And this is a broad overgeneralization,
but we're more concerned with the
quality of our lives in total. Um,
and this is why we don't often hear men
talking about work life balance in same
way that we do women then men tend to be.
And so one of the things that is important
to think about here is who do we have
as models for what warrior women in
leadership look like or what women leaders
look like generally.
And as I talked through warrior women
as a concept in the first stages of
getting ready for this talk,
one of the things that really struck
me is that going back in our history,
women in general have lost a lot
of our history. It's been erased.
And there's a lot that's been written
about this generally really encourage you
to look at it cause you'll be amazed
by what has been wiped from the history
books.
But we have had stories going all the way
back to like the Odyssey of how men go
through journeys that make them leaders.
Um,
the hero's journey is a trope that
we're all deeply familiar with. Um,
and one of the things that we haven't
had historically is the journey of a
heroin.
What is the journey of a woman look
like when we are progressing toward our
highest leadership?
And so one of the things that I want to
start with today is a discussion of what
the heroine's journey might look like in
the context of the history that we know
of from the hero's journey.
So the heroine's journey is
one that as an initial matter,
I want to say this about, it's not
like we go through this journey once.
One of the things that the studies
show about, the way that women learn,
for instance,
is that we learned cyclical sick quickly,
generally much more than we
learn in a linear fashion.
And so you may have noticed that my
corporate logo for instances a spiral,
there's a reason for that.
It's because the journey that we are
on is women leaders continues to cycle
around over and over again.
So what I'm going to share with you
today in the context of this journey is
something that I want to make very clear.
You're not just going to go through once.
Some heroin's journeys are
harder than others. Right? Um,
we're in a particular one as a
culture right now for women leaders.
That is quite brutal. I think we can
all agree. Um, and yet at the same time,
we cycle back continuously to learn over
and over again the things that we need
to learn on our path.
So as you think through this for yourself
in the context of what this might mean
for your life, as you think through what
it might mean for you in the context of,
um, the, the women you know,
and the women you work with,
please remember that it's not like this
is all just an over, I'm done game.
I wish it was, it would probably
be a lot easier on all of us. Um,
so where we start the
warrior woman journey,
the heroine's journey is first
in the place of illusion.
And when we think about
women's leadership,
this is the place where
we talk about conformity.
So it's the idea that, um,
if we dress a certain way,
if we lean in enough, and don't
get me wrong, I'm a fan of Sheryl,
but I have to say I have very strong
opinions about what meaning has done for
women leaders and they're
not all very good. Um,
if we show up in the right way as
assertive but not too assertive,
as opinionated, but not too
opinionated, if we smile enough, um,
if we are people pleasing enough,
we will get along just fine in these
traditional masculine leadership
environments,
that is the place of illusion.
And I'm gonna talk through a little bit
more what this looks like in greater
detail, but this is where we started our
journey with the belief that if we cope,
if we have coping skills that work for us,
then everything will be fine.
Unfortunately,
I think many of us can recognize that
that's generally not the way it works.
And so the next stage, the heroine's
journey is the stage of the trial.
And this is the place where you recognize
that your coping mechanisms have
failed you.
That you can still do it all.
And do it all in the way that we've been
told you have to do it to succeed as a
woman and still not have it happen.
And part of that is systemic.
And part of that is because we've been
taught that this is the only way that we
can do it. Don't worry, we're
going deeper into all of this. Um,
the next stage of the heroine's
journey is the one of awakening.
And this is really the place of choice.
You have a choice about whether or not
you're going to just continue coping or
you have a choice about whether or
not you're going to rise and fight.
And I don't necessarily mean
this in the wonder woman way,
but that's kind of a nice little image
to get in your head if you would care to.
The awakening is the moment of
recognizing that where we have been,
it can no longer continue and where we're
going has to be something different.
And we are the agent of that change
either individually or collectively.
Then comes the descent.
And this is the really kind of like not
nice place in the heroine's journey. Um,
this is the place where we
start to recognize the cost
and we recognize the cost
of what we have paid to
get where we are currently.
We recognize the cost
of continuing to fight.
We recognize that nothing is ever going
to quite be the same from where we find
ourselves.
And by the way,
this all may sound very
culturally familiar in terms
of where we find ourselves
right now as well. Um, and it is
the place where we choose our tools.
And before we leave today, I'm going to
talk through what some of these tools,
Aka weapons might look like in the
context of warrior women in leadership.
But it is a place where we determined
what it is that we need to succeed in a
new model, the dissent, the pit,
and the bottom of the heroine's
journey as the hurricane.
This is the place where we experienced
the Maelstrom of transformation.
Um, some of you who follow me on
Facebook now that I have this,
this thing that I talk about in terms
of where we are culturally right now,
which is the cauldron of transformation
and the way it feels like everything is
on fire.
We're boiling so much is changing in our
culture and in our world right now and
in our nation and it's
swirling all around us.
The dangerous point of the hurricane
is that sometimes there are points of
relief. It's like the eye of
the storm and we're like, oh,
maybe it's not quite so bad.
Maybe I can let my guard down,
maybe I don't have to fight so hard.
And then Lo and behold,
the next thing you know,
and the next day you're back in it.
And we're off to the races again.
So the hurricane is really the bottom
and it's where we need the most,
the most tools that we can
possibly, um, prepare ourselves for.
The next stage is loss.
And this is really the place where we
come face to face with the grief of what
we have to sacrifice in order to move
on to a new way of doing things. Um,
this is a place, by the way, that many
of us find ourselves in right now. Um, I,
you know, as uh, as I mentioned,
I host this daily broadcast on
Facebook called resistance live.
And just last night I had
to post something about, um,
I know everybody feels like they're in
a pit of despair and in the pit of grief
based on what has happened in the last
couple of days in our nation, um, please,
you know, recognize the grief is
real and also recognize that it's,
this place that we're in is not going
to last forever lost on the heroine's
journey necessarily leads to intervention.
Now,
some of you who may know the historic
heroes' dirties may recognize this as the
point where like the gods send
into tools, right? Um, you know,
Zeus kind of throws down the lightning
bolts and all of a sudden everything gets
better.
In our case intervention is actually
really about connection because it's about
taking on our own agency and connecting
with other women to move forward.
And again, we're going to talk
through this in a bit more depth,
but intervention is the moment of change.
It's the moment where we adopt our own
agency and step forward to make the world
more of what we want as
women. Um, and then rebirth.
That's the place where we really build
the future and continue to move forward
toward the world that we want to live in.
And then we return to our home territory
back to the top of the cycle. And again,
remember we're spiraling through
all of this all the time.
So rebirth and return is really
about return to a place of stasis,
not returned to the place
that we weren't before.
And so the journey of the
warrior woman is one that,
and this is going to be a theme in what
we discussed next is a place of constant
growth. It's not like the change ever
stops. It may ease up from time to time,
but the growth is continuous.
So where does this take us in the
context of women in leadership and
particularly in corporate,
but also in government and politics
and nonprofit and our lives and how we,
how we move forward.
So the first place we start on this
is we're at the place of illusion,
which is that what we were
promised is a lie. Um,
and this one is a particularly tough one,
I think for a lot of us to swallow because
for many of us who came up as women
leaders, what we were told was, again,
you do all these things right and
it's gonna be just fine, right?
All you have to do is x, Y, and Z. And
every time that you don't quite make it,
there's just one more little
thing that you need to do.
You add to that the myth that
women have been indoctrinated with,
which is the idea that
we can have it all right,
that there isn't all to even have.
And that if we do all the right things
in terms of our home life and our work
life and you know,
we cope and we hire the right help when
we needed or we seek out other resources
just to make it all work, that somehow
we're going to hit some perfect balance.
It's going to allow us to feel like we've
hit some arbitrary measure of success.
This whole thing is a lie. Um, and the,
the key point about this illusion that I
want to just make at the moment is that
we're starting to see all
of this disintegrate right
now in our culture, right?
The idea that, you know, again,
me two maps very strongly on to
what I'm going to talk about today,
but the idea that,
you know,
we have to just put up with a certain
degree of discrimination and a little bit
of harassment here,
we're just not going to talk about it.
This is just part of what you have to put
up with in order to achieve on the job.
All of that lie illusion.
So where does this take us to now?
We get to the point of
betrayal next in the journey.
And what I want to say about this is that
women's leadership advocacy has done a
lot, right? I don't want to discount that.
There are some very powerful voices out
there in the leadership methodology that
I work in, in my industry who have done
an awful lot to help women succeed.
But what we have failed to do is teach
women how to become their own best
advocates to teach women how to work
together as change agents in leadership.
And so to me,
lifelong feminist right here,
I just want to say that very big believer
in the principles of equality and
equity that many of us are working toward,
we have not gone far enough in the context
of helping women to claim their own
authority.
Um,
it feels often as though what we're
doing is pleading for change rather than
stepping forward and effecting
change ourselves. Um,
and so the standpoint of betrayal is
the point where we recognize that the
coping skills that we had before that
we have been taught sometimes top I want
another or not enough to
get us where we want to go.
So the next place that
we come to his awakening,
and this is the principle of why
we need warrior women. So you know,
one of the things that I want to emphasize
here when I talk about this is that
the impact of powerful embodied activists,
women leaders on corporate cultures
and the world is potentially dramatic.
Um, because one of the things that we have
to recognize is that we have different
ways of leading than what
we have seen traditionally.
And the studies bear this out,
right? We are more collaborative.
We are more communicative corporations
that have more women on their boards of
directors are investigated less, they're
more productive, they're more profitable,
they generate more revenue, generally
speaking, compared to their peers. Uh,
and all of this has to do with the
fact that women as leaders connect.
So warrior women in every
environment can make a difference.
Assuming that we are empowered to
step forward and create change.
And so the point of awakening is the
point that each one of us decides that we
are going to step forward and claim our
ability to advocate for different models
of leadership.
Um,
and I want to encourage all of you and
no matter where you find yourselves in
your career points at this point,
to think about what's the choice that you
have in front of you right now to make
more of a difference in your lives
and your working environments and your
culture in your world.
What's the choice that you are faced with
right now that may lead you to become
more of a voice for the change
that you want to see in the world?
Because it benefits everything. It
impacts everything that we do right now.
So this brings me to a point of
critique. Here we are in the descent. Um,
and one of the things that you all may
remember from back in 2016 is that when
we had a Hillary Clinton
running for president,
and we saw a lot of the sort of what I
like to refer to his lady power movements
or commodity feminism,
right?
All of these kind of like pet powder
pink websites for women's empowerment.
And if you just wear the right suit
and you put on the right pair of heels,
everything's going to be okay.
And I will admit that in my
industry I worked for some of these,
like what a lot of people don't know is
that I actually used to collaborate with
Ivanka Trump, um, many months ago. Uh,
but that is a prime example
of commodity feminism.
It's selling a solution that
is not internal to yourself.
And so what part of the messaging here
in terms of how do we build stronger
women's leadership? It has to be
about self origination. You know,
one of the things that I talk about all
the time in corporate environments where
I train and teach women leaders is the
idea that when we change what's on the
inside, we inevitably change
what's on the outside.
And so it's not like there is some easy
one size fits all solution that shifts
us toward equity.
We have to be that.
We have to be empowered internally to
make the shifts that are necessary to step
forward to effect change. So, um,
commodity feminism is the descent.
And by the way, this is also the point
where we start to recognize the cost,
right? Where we start to look inside
ourselves and see, I have been guilted,
I have been shamed into
not being good enough.
I had been told that my
voice is meaningless.
What does that mean in terms of what
are the tools that I'm going to pick up
next?
How can I communicate more effectively?
How do I need to refine the way that I
operate in every environment so that I am
using my voice?
And so one of the things that we
talk about when we talk about tools,
and I'll talk about this in just a
couple of minutes a little bit more,
is the idea that we do need to adopt
new weapons as women in leadership.
So that may look like things
like nonviolent communication.
And for those of you who don't know,
nonviolent communication strategies were
developed by Marshall Rosenberg in the
1970s and there are means by which you
can effectively communicate your needs
and wants so that they are heard from the
perspective of the person on the other
side of the table from
you with compassion.
This is a skill set by the way that I
think everybody needs in every corporate
environment. Um, it is very
much about this, what I
experienced, what I witnessed,
what I value, and then requesting
buyin in a collaborative way.
That skill set is one that for women
in leadership is absolutely critical
because we need to be able to learn to
advocate in ways that are different from
pounding the table to demand what we want.
Very much traditional
masculine leadership model.
Whereas our collaborative means of asking
for change and propelling forward and
communication can actually shift things
and help others to see the value of what
we're after.
So that's one tool,
but I will also just add that in a lot
of corporate environments these days,
there's a lot of toxicity underway.
And some of the tools that we need to
think about empowering ourselves with our
tools that, you know, five,
10 years ago I couldn't teach
in corporate environments.
Things like how do you protect your
energy so that when you're under attack,
which we're about to get to in a minute,
we're getting into the hurricane,
you know that you aren't,
you're not taking on and internalizing
the negative messaging that you're
getting.
How can you step forward and feel
empowered in your body and in your
presentation so that you are making an
impact that shows others that you are not
to be messed with.
All of these skill sets and tools
are new ones that we need to learn.
And so one of the things that I do
recommend for women leaders who are in the
ground on the battle,
on the battlefield every day with
this is that you think through how the
experience that you have as a
warrior woman is affecting you.
Are you internalizing negative messaging?
Are you having a hard time with how you
can advocate and succeed and keep going?
You may need to refine your skill
set in this way. And you know,
these are the baseline on the ground
skills that I teach every day in corporate
environments.
Um,
but it is an important point of
recognition that we need new tools for new
times.
So now we get to the hurricane and this
is how worried are women are punished.
So, um, you know,
one of the things that I like to be
very blunt about in the warrior woman
journey that I'm talking about today is
nobody is saying this is easy, right?
No one is saying that like,
we,
we're all going to step forward and like
kick some ass and win and it's all just
going to get better overnight. Um,
warrior women are punished relentlessly.
All we have to do is look at the 2016
election. It's about how you talk,
the sound of your voice, how you laugh,
what you wear, your hair, your makeup,
your body,
whether or not you're meeting certain
codes that convey certain bits of
information that make
you qualified or not.
And I will also just add that as we work
to transform our culture and we work to
transform our society privileges
a hard thing to let go of. Right?
We see the experience right now
of old ways of doing things,
old models of leadership,
old means of operation clinging on by
their fingernails to avoid any change in
the world.
Um,
and one of the things that mean that
means is that crazy attacks will come out
of nowhere. Pizza Parlors in Washington
DC come to mind, for instance. Um,
the level at which we have to be prepared
to go to battle for the world that we
want to build is significant.
And as well,
it's critical in this environment that
we work together to hold one another up.
Um, so one of the things that I talk
about when we talk about the importance of
collaboration as a way
through and connection as a
way through is the issue of
why we're better off together.
So one of the things that I want
to point out here by the way,
is that traditional male models of
leadership encourage women to compete with
one another.
That's because we've been told that
there's only room for so many of us at the
talk that by the way, as
a part of the big lie. Um,
and one of the things that it means
is that when we are competing with one
another,
when we are tearing one another down,
when we are not helping to lift other
women up in the corporate environment or
elsewhere,
um,
we are not focused on how we can work
together to actually affect change. Um,
it's a really convenient self reinforcing
mechanism of patriarchy that women
like to tear each other down
and beat each other up. Um,
and so one of the things that I really
encourage here is that we think about how
we can instead adopt a model. This is a
very serious thought leadership pivot.
But instead adopt a model that says,
when one of us wins, we all rise.
This is a very hard thing for
women to internalize honestly,
because we've been raised in a culture
that says that's just not the way it
works. But my standpoint
on this is the following,
when we recognize how much
damage we've done to one another,
and this is really why we're
sitting in the place of loss.
When we talk about this,
how much harm we've done to one another
by not adopting a thought process that
says,
let me see how I can help my sister up.
We recognize all the time that's been
lost that would have affected change
before now. And it also propels us
to make change more in the future.
So the image I like to work
with on this is the idea of um,
an an Everest sending pillar of humanity.
Women,
if you would like to think about it.
And that way it can just be women.
But I honestly think about
it as gender neutral.
And the idea of it is that we leave
no one behind. And hopelessness.
We leave no one behind
without opportunity and so on.
One of her sisters is
falling off the pillar.
You are the person who leans down with
your hand to grab her and pull her back
up. This as a, as an image, as a metaphor,
functions so well in the idea of how we
can affect change in the environments
that we are in.
Because when we see someone struggling,
another woman's struggling. When we see
another woman working so hard to succeed,
what can we do to help lift her up
rather than saying, oh, she sucks.
Let me just let her fail
over there on her own.
The more that we can consider the
collaborative nature of how we can work
together and abandoned this idea of the
zero sum game, you know, I, I, by the way,
the quote I always refer to on
this front is Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
She was asked one time when,
how many women needed to be on the supreme
court to make her happy. And she said,
nine and the reporter was horrified by
that story and she said, what? You know,
for centuries it was nine
men on the Supreme Court.
What's wrong with the idea of a s,
you know,
all women on the Supreme Court all put
together and it's such a shocking idea to
us,
right?
Because we've been convinced that there's
just this tiny little slot that we
have to fit into.
So the pivot of abandoning the zero sum
game and then moving toward a place of
collective and collaborative advocacy
as women makes a huge difference in what
we are able to accomplish.
And so that takes us to several
points of intervention here. Um,
one of which is how to be
a warrior woman at work.
And we're going to talk through a couple
of different ways in which we can be a
warrior woman here to really
affect change. So, um,
and I'll just say to all
the guys in the room,
I want to just really appreciate your
listening to all of this too because the
skill sets are honestly gender neutral,
but from the perspective of what warrior
women need to do in the workplace.
Um, if we're at a really
interesting turning point right now.
So to me this is about a refusal
to accept the status quo.
So if you are in a working environment
where you've seen instances of
unconscious bias and you
have not shattered out,
this is now where it needs to start.
If you are aware in your workplace that
somebody has been discriminated against
or harassed,
silence is no longer an option.
We are really in a place right now from
the standpoint of advocacy where we're
at zero tolerance.
And again,
me too is a prime example of this because
you see all the seizing frustration
underneath the surface of what women
and others, it's not just women,
but women in predominant numbers had
experienced that has caused such rage,
such rage at every,
all the dreams that have been lost.
All the opportunities that
have been taken from us,
he experiences that have
been mapped onto our bodies.
And from the perspective
of how we shift this,
some of it has to be about
speaking the unspokens right?
For the first time ever saying
the things that we had been told,
we are not allowed to say telling the
stories that we've been told over and over
again that we are not allowed to tell.
And simply the use of our voices in that
way in work environments changes the
corporate culture. And I'll tell you, you
know, I do work inside investment banks,
huge financial institutions,
publicly traded companies all the time.
The ability of women when they are
empowered to actually speak the truth of
their experiences in those environments
can change those cultures overnight
because all of the sudden it's
not like they're unspoken things,
hidden stories that are oppressing
certain qualities and preventing women
fundamentally from living
out their true gifts. Right?
Cause this is really what it's
all about for me. It's this,
it's about talent and it's about why
we're here. It's about talent and purpose.
And so one of the other things that's
really important to me when I talk about
warrior women in leadership at work is
that we think through why we're here.
What's the purpose, right? And
if we look back at the metrics,
I started with a traditional
masculine models of leadership,
only valuing money and time,
what worry women and women in general
in leadership bring to the table as an
idea that we are all here with certain
gifts that can be contributed to the
collective.
And the metric that I talk about when
I go in and even in gender neutral
environments teach about leadership is
the idea that we shift from that metric
toward a metric of growth, continuous
growth, continuous growth of service.
And part of that requires each and every
one of us to be able to recognize the
gifts and the purpose for
why we're here fundamentally.
So to me,
one of the things that has to happen in
order for us to be able to fully embody
our gifts, to live on our purpose,
to serve out in the way that we,
we need to serve,
um,
is that those stories are taken away so
that the true totality of our voices can
be heard.
Um,
and so part of this aspect of stepping
completely into our leadership as warrior
women has to be about that use of voice
that then allows us to contribute our
gifts in different ways. Does that
make sense to everybody? I hope so. Um,
and you know, one of the things that
I want to say about this as well,
just while we're on the topic of purpose
is that if we are measuring success by,
um, consistent standards of
growth, are we growing ourselves?
Are we growing our teams?
And this is not like the bottom line
revenue growth that we're talking about,
right? It's about the growth of the
impact that you want to make in the world.
If we are focused on that,
then we are asking different questions
about what success looks like.
And this is where we get to, to have a
true benefit for women in leadership,
right? Because if we are modeling success
on our growth, on our collaboration,
on the difference that
we make in the world,
then inherently we care more about
things like the quality of our lives.
We care more about whether or not we
can create work environments where, um,
you know, women can contribute even
if they've got children at home.
We work to create cultural shifts
that allow for, um, you know,
childcare to be absolutely available to
all of us so that we have an opportunity
to contribute at the
totality of our gifts.
So the mental pivot away from money
and time is the only metric towards
different models of success is really
key here. And I hope that makes sense.
Okay. Um, just a little bit
on warrior woman at home, I'm,
one of the things that I just want
to point out here is that, um,
even in households where a
women are primary earners,
we still do two thirds of the housework.
And we do right now at
this moment in time,
50% more childcare than women did
in the fifties. Believe it or not,
that's because models are parenting
have changed. Pure research.
If you go look at these
numbers, it's astonishing. Um,
one of the things that I want to make
plain when we talk about cultural shifts
here is that everything that we do,
by the way, is political. I mean,
I think this is kind of a given if you've
been in a feminist movement at all in
any way,
shape or form.
But then most intimate conversations
that we have about our needs and our and
being supported inevitably impact
the way that we are in the world.
And so one of the things that is key here
in the way that I think about this is
that if we are not able to ask for
what we need in our home environments,
it also therefore becomes
much more difficult for us
to ask for it in the world.
And so even at the tiny
baseline conversations that
we have with our partners
and our spouses about like
who's doing the dishes, right?
Like who's taking care of the kids?
Do we need help? How can I get help?
I myself am a single mom and I'm really
big on like can we create collaborative
models in our communities that can help
to support women in different ways that
maybe have not been discussed before,
that are outside of our old school
historic model of, you know,
women doing women's work at home and
men being out working in the world.
We need to start getting creative
about the solutions that we seek here.
Those proactive conversations where
we draw a line in the sand and say,
this isn't working for me anymore.
Let me think creatively about
how to make it different.
Inevitably lead us to places of
being able to have more high stakes
conversations out in the world at large.
Um, and so we can't forget that. Right.
And I also just want to
mention one other thing here.
I do not believe in work life
balance. I think, you know, again,
it's like a total myth that it could even
be possible. I think what is possible,
however, is to have lives that are
in alignment with what we value.
And for each of us, that's
a unique metric, right? What
do I value most in my life?
How do I create a life that gives me that?
Um,
and if we are not thinking about
that individually for ourselves,
we also can't create solutions
for it in the collective.
So starting at the baseline of what do
I need most in my own home is a really
important way to lead to being able and
more courageous to have higher stakes
conversations in other
places. Um, okay. And lastly,
the point of intervention of how
to be a warrior woman in the world.
So one of the things about activist women,
women's leadership that to
me is so compelling at this
moment in time is that we
are in a place where we actually
have an opportunity to make a massive
difference.
Like the world is cracking open right now.
And the opportunity for change and to
create a future that we want to live in is
more compelling now and more
possible now. I even saying, um,
despite the dark days that we seem to be
living in then it's been for quite some
time. I think we can all,
you know, I'm 46 years old,
those of us who are sixties and
seventies babies may have some vague
recollection of other historic turning
points in time where opportunities like
this felt like they were possible. This
moment feels particularly rich to me. Um,
and I want to remind you all that,
you know, in lots of mythologies, um,
the cremation ground,
the place where everything is burned to
ash is actually the most fertile place
for growth. It's the place where you
can plant seeds and create a future. Um,
and so where we find ourselves
right now really has to be,
and I'm such a big advocate for this,
and my daily resistance broadcasts a
place where we think about the future that
we want to live in, into. And we start
living from that place right now.
So that means, for instance, that
we don't, um, how should I put it?
We don't,
uh,
we don't get down in the gutter and fight
dirty if that's not the future that we
want to live into. And it means that if
we make choices about how we advocate,
we advocate from a place of kindness
and compassion and acceptance.
It also means that we are constantly
working toward the future that we want.
And so to me,
part of this as well is about how do we
stand up and fight for the future that
we want in our world for our children.
Um, you know, in government, in,
in the corporate
environments that we work in.
How everyday can we step into modeling
the future that we want to live in?
Not Easy. Like I want just want
to say this is not easy. You know,
managing our emotions,
especially in times of turmoil and stress
and trauma and our nation is really,
really hard and we have to envision the
world that we want to live into where
the people who are going to lead the
way on that. By the way, I mean I think,
I hope that makes sense that like women
who stepped forward and really own this
moment and take it through
the transformation. You know,
this is like a birth process we're in
right now as a culture. And as a country,
we know how to give birth. Right? Um,
and one of the things that I think is
key there is that we have to claim it,
right? No one's swooping in to
save us on his front, right?
We have to be the people who lead the
change at this moment in time to build
that future because we can see it. So, um,
it's a very unique opportunity where
we are right now, honestly. And, um,
if I could kind of, um, leave
everybody with a thought here about,
um, what we're, what we're leading into,
the question I get asked more often than
not is why or what is this vision that
you have of the future? What is this
going to look like? When we got there, um,
I did a speaking tour this fall and that
was the number one question that I got
asked in every location around the country
was what's this vision of the future
that you have for women and for all of us?
Um,
and so to me the point of this is that
we have an opportunity now to create a
world where there is equity,
where from the standpoint of even just
corporate hiring and recruiting po
policies,
like where are we going to recruit
the next generation of women leaders?
We can do all of that differently
where we can do things like, you know,
pay equity analysis inside our companies
and see how people are getting paid
from that all the way up to
how do we create, um, you know,
a place where no one is left behind,
your hopelessness.
A government that represents all of us.
I'm a world where everyone
has opportunity. What, what
does that look like? Um,
to me it looks like a place where we
know that every human life has value and
where we step outside of the arbitrary
hierarchies of race and gender and
national origin and preference and
everything else and orientation.
Um,
and think through the idea that the idea
that there's an arbitrary hierarchy of
humans is just that it's just a myth,
right? And so if we approach the world,
we want to live in from a place of all
of us having equality and equity and
value,
that means necessarily that we can't
have policies that some of us who don't
benefit others,
right?
That create artificial
differences between us as humans.
And so, um, to me this is
kind of like the big Kahuna.
We're in a big Kahuna moment right now
and warrior women will change the world
by being the people who write
the path. Right? Um, so, uh,
I know this,
a lot of this has been a lot more esoteric
and heading than I anticipated it was
going to be when I ran through it
this morning for like the fourth time.
But I think I'm going to wind
down there and just say that, um,
for all the women in the room,
I really want to encourage
you to think through like,
what's the next step to taking your
voice to the next level and where can you
step more fully into your own leadership,
take up new skills and new
armor and new weapons, um,
to change the world and make it better.
And to recognize as well
that your heroine's journey
is your own story and you
get to choose how you live it and that
inevitably there's a heroine and a
warrior woman and all of us.
I think that's what I believe and
how we get there is within our own,
uh, our own path and our own
story and our own dividing.
But that it's really critical
that we are action oriented in it,
that we claim it ourselves rather than
allowing ourselves to just be pushed
through the flow of our lives.
We really need to swim with the current,
if that makes sense.
Um,
and step fully into the opportunities
that are there for us to battle for the
world that we want to live in.
So I think that's it for today.
Very heady and esoteric,
but I hope you guys enjoyed it.
I'm more than happy to take
some questions if he was like,
well, thanks for coming in. I
have like many, many questions.
I'll limit it to one. That's fine.
You can ask many, many questions.
Maybe we can talk after that,
but my question is around I try my
best to subscribe to feminism blogs and
listen to different speakers and,
and promote.
But then I feel that when
I am sometimes asked to,
uh,
summarize what I've heard of it,
very difficult time summarizing it
because I don't live the experiences that
many women experience. Um,
and do you have tips and,
yeah. Good question. When
are you asked to summarize it
generally with other men?
Yeah. Okay. Got It. So that's,
that's a really interesting point
because let me just say this.
I am a very big believer that we are
not just at a turning point for women.
We're at a turning point for men.
And I talk quite a bit about the idea
of sacred masculinity and modeling good
masculinity to other men.
So first of all,
Kudos to you for being willing to
be a change agent on that friends.
Cause there are a lot of men who aren't
willing to even make the effort. Um,
but the second thing I would say about
this is that there is in some sense,
um, no substitute for men
talking to women about their own,
about the experiences of women,
meaning that you can
summarize to a certain extent.
And of course you can do it to the best
of your ability and the next thing that
comes out of your mouth. If it
were me, it would be, by the way,
are you talking to your wife about this?
Are you talking to your sister about this?
Are you talking to your daughter about
her experiences so that you're learning
it? Um, you know, I,
I'm learning it through the prism
of multiple women's experiences,
if that makes sense.
And I will also just add that there is
nothing wrong with asking what can I do
to do it better? You know, what
can I do to make it better for you?
What can I do to make it better for women?
Generally?
How can I be a better advocate? So, um,
I think it's not just about how can
I summarize what I'm reading about,
but also how can I propel men to be more
engaged in the conversation about what
a healthier masculinity would look like
and how to make the world a better place
for women generally. Does
that make sense? Yeah.
Yep.
Thank you so much for coming here.
Thank you so much for your talk
is actually pretty nice. Uh,
and really enlightening.
Um,
you mentioned a couple of times this
idea of a masculine model of leadership.
I was wondering what in your view,
a feminine model of leadership or
a gender neutral board agendas,
new gender neutral model of
leadership would look like?
So this is a really,
this is actually what we normally do when
I go in and do corporate training and
consulting. So you, you've given me
a, um, a nice little transition here.
So we have something we call the aligned
leadership model, which is a model that,
um,
that actually has what we would consider
it to be like more feminine qualities
of leadership attached to it.
It is fundamentally an emotionally
intelligent model of leadership.
And it starts from the place of thinking
through leadership from, I mean,
there's 12 points on a pivot.
We all like it would take me a
whole other hour to go through it,
but fundamentally it starts from a place
of the most effective leadership in
today's environment. Being leadership
that starts with curiosity and compassion.
Um, and so it's not, I'm,
I am the, I'm the king.
I am the ultimate note all of
how this company should run. Um,
but really more of a more of
a questioning, a consistent
questioning of how can,
how can we improve? What am I good
at? What, what does my team good at?
How can I look at what my gifts are and
where I'm weak and build an organization
that fills in the gaps? How can I value
everyone's gifts on my team? Right?
And it also talks through the concept
that I shared with you today. Uh,
growth is one of the main
metrics of success. Um, so to me,
I wouldn't want to call it a feminine
model of leadership. I think it's,
I think it's far more healthy,
right?
Are Align leadership model that we
teach is really about how do you create
healthy ecosystems inside companies
where everyone is functional and moreover
that is holistic so that it's not just
about what the person can perform at work.
I mean,
you guys are amazing in here by the way.
I have to say that of all the working
environments that I've stepped into,
this one seems to care the most about
the totality of the human beings who work
here. And that is amazing to me. Um, and,
and truly something to be honored
and admired and uplifted. Um,
but so many environments that I walk
into only care about what happens to the
individual in terms of how they
can provide for the company, right.
And how they can perform
when they're there.
And if somebody's spouses dying or
someone's child is having a crisis,
who cares? As long as the
bottom line needs are met. Um,
aligned leadership to me is
really about recognizing that, um,
that we're all connected,
that organizations are only as healthy
as the individuals who are within them.
And that,
um,
just in the same way that each of us have
gifts to contribute to the world, um,
organizations do as well.
And so mission is really critical and
important and making decisions based on
mission that are aligned with also all
the individuals that make up that mission,
um,
creates environments that people want
to live in and work in and are loyal to.
And that,
you know,
you can't imagine leaving and just talk
and talk to some of you today as I was
walking around before here. I mean,
that's very present here, right?
That degree of respect and understanding
of the way in which everybody who works
here is connected and the
needs of everyone being met.
So that to me is about as close as I can
get without doing like a full blown all
day long training like I normally do
in corporate environments on this. Um,
but yeah,
it really is about emotional intelligence
fundamentally as a principal and then
mission and purpose and making all of
your decisions about your people and the
people who work for you as if we're a
family because we are. Right. Makes Sense.
Okay.
Good.
So I had a question about
something you mentioned earlier,
earlier you said that these stories
of many women had been erased.
Is there someplace place we could go to
look at and we could find those stories
that you've been with breasts?
Well, so if they've been a it, it's
that you have to do a lot of digging.
So I will tell a story about this,
this kind of um,
that really brought this home to me.
But I will tell you that it took me
about three hours of like serious,
serious digging on the Internet to find
anything that remotely looked like a,
so my, my maiden name is crow.
Nice. Um, as you all know,
and my father is really into ancestry.
So one of the things that we discovered
when he did all of this work is that, um,
our family on my father's
side is originally from
Alsace Lorraine and the, um,
the spelling of our name originally
in German means iron crown.
And so I went digging
because my father was killed.
We were ironworkers apparently. And
like the 15th century, you know,
my dad's gone all the way back through
all this, but I went digging to see,
well like what's the
reference point for this name?
And I discovered in like three hours of
kind of falling down a rabbit hole. Um,
this is, you know, the old lawyer in
me with a researcher, um, that there,
there was this thing called the iron
crown. Some you may know historically. Um,
but the iron crown was
originally commissioned by, um,
a queen in like the third century.
Um,
whose name I'm now going to forget
because nobody's ever heard of her because
the history has been completely erased.
But I did a whole podcast on this podcast
called the women's leadership podcast.
I did a podcast on justice experience,
uh,
recognizing that there had been a
woman who basically had been the head,
had something like that,
something the size of the Ottoman Empire
at some point in our history that none
of us know about.
Like,
I literally had not heard of this woman
ever before until I went digging for all
of this because the stories
that we talking about
history or the stories of men
and so you know,
to some extent it's about your degree of,
we're back to curiosity again, your degree
of curiosity about women's history. Um,
and to some extent it's
also about recognizing that
many of our traditions have
always been oral traditions.
And so this is one of the reasons why
women's storytelling still is really
important.
And one of the reasons why I encourage
women who want to know about even the
history of their own families
to go interview their
grandmother's on tape before
they die,
um,
because the otherwise it gets lost
if it's not written down somewhere.
I wish I could say that there,
there was like a magic, um,
on a racer button that would
bring all of this back.
But I think some of it has to be about
how far are you as an individual willing
to do the day to then share it
with the collective. I mean, I,
this is a great opportunity by the way,
for a project like somebody should start
a reclaiming women's history project if
it's not been done already.
Um,
just so that we can start to see
like all the gaps there. Um, yeah,
so that's my answer to that individual
individual choice I think at this point.
So I am lucky, um, to,
to be in a leadership position and I have
a team that has one other woman on it
and the rest are men and the team that
I lead are generally somewhere in the
range of about 15 years
behind me career wise.
And what I've tried to do is to adapt
my style to the needs of each person on
the team because they are very different,
their experiences are different, the,
their communication styles are different.
Um,
and try to give that hand
up to all of them. Yep. Um,
and what I have found in the
last year or two is that, uh,
I sometimes have people call me out as,
as I'm favoring the woman on the team,
even though when I sit down and talk
to them about all of the ways that I'm
investing in their careers and, and, and,
and the things that I'm doing for them,
they recognize that they're getting as
much or more. Yup. Um, and so, you know,
as you were talking about our
responsibility of kind of bring, you know,
bringing up other women, you know, what,
what about the people who stand by
on the sidelines and go, we'll see.
You're just playing favorites and
that's just know better. Right,
right, right. So, um, so it's hard to give
up privilege. You know, I was so excited.
It's really hard to give up print
woods and some of it, some of,
some of what the communication
that we all need to learn. Uh,
I think to do better is also to say
equity is not about playing favorites.
Right.
Meaning that the image that I,
that I share with people about equity
versus equality is that in order to reach
true equity culturally,
you do have to lift up people who
historically have not had the extra lift,
right? It's like you think about,
think about it from this perspective,
the images that I've seen on this is,
it's so descriptive as you know,
you've got people at three different
heights behind a fence, right?
And equality is that everybody gets to
stand on the same place on the fence.
Equity is that everybody can see over it,
right?
And so sometimes that means that
from a historic perspective,
you ha you have to do things
differently in order to create equity.
There will be a point, hopefully in the
future where we don't have to do that.
But to me, first of all,
that's not playing favorites.
So I wouldn't call it that.
You know, I guess it's the thing,
you can shout it out and say,
actually that's not what I'm doing and
do what you're already doing there.
Which I think sounds like, I hope it's
working to a certain extent. Um, but the,
but the flip side of that as well is that,
um,
if we do not actually start
to make different choices
in corporate environments,
leaders, nothing shifts, right?
Like my biggest client is a
publicly traded investment bank. Um,
and they have,
they discovered they did some research
last year and they discovered that only
4.7% of their senior executives are women,
even though they hire 35%,
um,
as women and they're losing people and
they've never kind of investigated why,
which is crazy to me, but
they've never looked at it. Um,
one of the things that
I've had to say to them is,
why are you not recruiting a
historically women's colleges? Right?
Why are you not thinking about maybe the
fact that you need to provide different
kinds of leadership training for women
so that they understand how to navigate
this environment better?
Why are your senior male leaders not
signing on to initiatives that say,
we're making a commitment as an
organization to gender parity?
And here's what we're
willing to do about it.
Here's the investment that
we're willing to make.
Here's the training programs
that we want to ascribe to you.
Because the other thing is
that the unfortunate thing
about being a woman leader
right now in some environments is that
you have to do the emotional labor of
educating people about what
it is that needs to change.
And it is so much easier if senior male
leaders also sign on to that as allies
so that the messaging comes
from other men. Right?
We're back to this issue of how can you
kind of like how can other men work as
allies to educate other men about the
benefits of what's happening. So, um,
okay.
I Dunno, I don't want to tell you what
all the solutions should be for you,
but it does sound to me like you need
some male allies as well on this front who
can communicate this to your team in ways
that make sense so that you're not the
one that is bearing the burden of doing
the right thing and having them feel
like that's unfair.
Helpful.
Yeah.
And it was more,
I mean I feel like on our team we have
very good communication and we've talked
through this and yeah, and everybody's
on the same page. But as, as I,
as I look around and as you use that
analogy of kind of giving a hand up to
other women,
it is something that everybody kind of
has to think through in terms of is this
going to be misperceived as,
as preferential treatment or what's
the best way to communicate that?
It isn't really, and I think you did a
good job of covering that. Thank you.
Well,
you're welcome.
Hi. I wanted to get your thoughts on the
situation. It's not happening in this,
this company, another company
to a friend of mine, she uh,
she wanted to switch teams
within the same company,
had an offer with another team.
Uh,
she was pregnant a few weeks
before her delivery, um,
ducks to the manager, new new
manager, uh, is offered this position.
Um,
she based the devil's advocate thing.
I'm going to be gone few months.
Totally understand that the response,
we still want you here. We value here.
Babies born. It's been two months now.
Now she gets a call saying,
we think this position
is no longer a great fit.
We're not sure we would value you as much.
It's pretty reputed company.
I can tell you what it is. Very
close friend of mine. I'm angry. Um,
and uh,
the manager talks to her saying,
I want to grow the people who work on
clean the team to this manager will,
nothing's changed.
Her pregnancy hasn't changed.
The same people continue to be in the
team. Now there's suddenly a question,
the way she's responding to us that
she's paying the mentoring role for this
manager and saying, Hey, do what's right
for the team. Um, so business wise,
the right thing for the team is not to
wait for a couple of more months for her
to return back and which is
what is likely the manager.
We're hoping to hear from her.
Um,
and I don't want her to be in a position
where she's no longer going to be as
much valued. Uh, the other
options are he, we'll create one.
We'll create a new opportunity.
That's like one third of what
you were supposed to own.
It doesn't make sense from
owning the whole thing.
Why would I go back to winning a third?
This is a big corporate corporation here.
I don't want her to fight against this
corporation that her career would be
ruined after this. Um, and, and so she,
I mean if you just where the
business had it feels like, yeah,
the manager made a stupid mistake probably
to offer her a job when she's going
to disappear in a few months.
But I was happy that he did.
Thinking the long term potential
and the longterm value,
what do you typically recommend this,
I'm sure it's just one of many instances
that are happening out there today.
It's true. I, you know,
I have to say that it's really unfortunate
because I hear stories like this a
lot. Pregnancy discrimination
is still very real. Um, and I,
and I'm to the point where when I'm
coaching women leaders one on one,
we have conversations proactively when
they want to even get pregnant about how
they have to prepare their team for that,
how they have to prepare their senior
leadership for it, how to disclose it.
Women I coach through job transitions.
Like when do I tell people I'm
pregnant while I'm interviewing?
These are all incredibly
difficult questions that we
still have to think about,
which is crazy to me. But all that said
for your friend's situation, you know,
I guess my,
the lawyer in me initially says she
should find a good employment lawyer and
actually ask some questions about what,
what the strategy there has
to be from a legal standpoint.
And I know you don't want her to sue,
but I will tell you that the employment
lawyers that my company refers our
clients to help help people negotiate
situations like this so that they walk the
edge of it.
Meaning that like that manager knows that
he's doing something that's not quite
right.
You know,
I mean it's obvious or you wouldn't be
having the conversation the way that he's
having it. If she is able to come
back with something that says,
you made me this offer when I was
pregnant, you knew that I was pregnant.
I understand you now
want to grow the team,
but this is the offer that was made to me.
And I still add value here with
the right kind of language.
That's that like basically signals
that she knows what her rights are.
That may actually help the
situation dramatically.
And I can give you the number of,
I have a very dear friend who
like the past head of the, um,
the employment bar in DC
and knows everybody in the
country who does this kind
of work and could find
her someone to talk to.
But that would be an initial strategy
that I would want to approach it from.
And then from the place of thinking
through the business end of it, you know,
the idea of what value you add, um,
you know, her value has not changed.
And so to me, I don't see that
there's any business. He, he,
I don't think he made a mistake.
I think what's happening now is that
he's second guessing for all the
traditional stereotypical reasons.
Is she going to be available?
She's going to have a baby at home.
Is she going to be as dedicated to
the job as she was before? You know,
all those sorts of issues.
And some of that has to be about
her taking lead to say, I'm here,
I'm available, I'm ready, I want
this, I'm going to do it. Um,
nothing's going to fall through
the cracks. I'm committed.
It's sucks that women have to have these
conversations still forward looking,
but they do.
And um,
so I think it's gotta be the combination
of her own self advocacy to bring us
back to where we were.
We've been today and also she
definitely needs aware to just talk to,
and I'm more than happy to give you that
number after the fact if you would like.
Thank you.
Yeah.
That's all the time we have for questions.
Thank you very much everybody for coming.
And thank you very much. Elizabeth.
Thank you all.
[inaudible].